hi I'm Jenna Cole software engineer at
Google and also co-chair of cube plan
today I did a few note on kubernetes
project update and I'd like to give you
a recap on it so I had a kubernetes look
back and history of kubernetes starting
from Google created pork and then the
needed containers and then the docker
containers and then omega projects and
then we open sourced kubernetes and
until this day kubernetes has become
very popular and we have over 31,000
contributors and it's also one of the
highest philosophy projects on github
today kubernetes is very stable and
mature and we are celebrating the five
years anniversary for kubernetes and the
next focus around in the community will
be on extensibility I expect more people
to extend on top of kubernetes and then
scalability I expect we keep improving
the scalability limits and kubernetes
and the third focus will be around
reliability we need to fix the test
akkadian failures more holistically and
we need to do it together as a community
I expect you to contribute to coronaries
and if you have questions feel free to
meet us at Google foods thank you
[Music]